the coast of California around Monterey
Bay is known worldwide for its
spectacular rocky shoreline and its
fierce waves just a few kilometers off
its coast begins the slope of an
undersea Canyon the ranks among the
largest in the world
within its network of deep-sea valleys
the Monterey Canyon supports a richness
of life tiny shrimp-like crew to the
migrating baleen whales who feed on
[Music]
it may look like a bloodbath from above
the water but this gray whale is
actually feeding on millions the tiny
red krill thrive in these waters because
of the canyons deep upwelling currents
the massive daily vertical migration of
krill provides food for predators near
the surface of the water and for those
in its depths here two lives the
Humboldt squid which can grow to two
metres long when threatened it flashes
with colour and Jets itself through the
water to evade predators
the mola mola the world's largest bony
fish usually travels in the open sea it
lives on a diet heavy with jellyfish but
also lingers near kelp beds thick with
nutrients
otters to dying in the kelp beds these
mammals have no blubber such a high
metabolic rate that they must daily eat
about 20 percent of the body weight
their fur is the densest the animal
kingdom
[Music]
Monterey Bay is one of the places in the
world that is ideal for giant kelp often
called redwoods of the sea kelp can soar
up to 50 meters high
to thrive kelp needs a rocky seabed
plenty of nutrients and calm leaves it
also houses an amazing array of
creatures sea slugs purple sea urchins
tiny octopus and Mele Bay right at the
curve of Monterey Bay runs an equally
rich seasonal estuary Elkhorn Slough
it's shallow branches support marshes
and mud flats a critical habitat for
hundreds of species of birds and marine
life
[Music]
early in the 20th century Monterey's
cannery row became known for its vast
fishing industry overfishing nearly
wiped out populations of sardines salmon
and halibut
but in 1992 the federal government
designated 7,500 square kilometers of
ocean and sea floor around Monterey Bay
is worrying sanctuary
the diverse ecosystem found here has
made this area one of the most studied
parts of the ocean these studies have
brought about new understanding
appreciation greater protection for
Monterey Bay and its marine wildlife
you